[Music]
in this video you'll be able to realize
the potential dangers of spreading your
social content to thin across multiple
channels you'll also be able to explain
the pitfall of isolating content on a
single third-party social channel where
not everyone might be able to see it you
should be able to outline a new approach
to social posting that utilizes a blog
or some form of social media home base
and identify opportunities for more
streamlined conversion experiences in
existing social media campaigns so let's
get started with lesson 3 establishing
and benefiting from a social media home
base too many brands tend to be so busy
putting content out on different
channels that they miss the need and the
value of having a centralized hub and
what I mean by that is having one place
where all of the collateral that they're
creating for their social campaigns is
actually housed and accessible in one
centralized hub and in general they do a
pretty good job with social media
they're active on Twitter they have a
youtube channel they're on Facebook and
Pinterest and all sorts of different
places so what happens is your target
audience can miss a lot because social
media efforts are scattered so people
who find one type of content they don't
always know how you also have a YouTube
channel hey you also have an Instagram
channel so they're not necessarily aware
of all the possibilities now if I
actually go into the Annie's website now
I'm going to find out about their grants
for gardens program and I've been a fan
of Annie's for years but I had no idea
this program existed until I use them as
an example to go and pull screenshots
for this so it's important to keep in
mind that if you are utilizing your
social channels is a way to draw people
into deeper content on a site that you
own you have much more flexibility and
ability to pass them through different
types of content now the other thing
about having a home base a place where
your content on third-party channels
points back to
is that then your social media efforts
help boost your overall marketing
efforts simply because of the way they
impact everything online so for example
if you're using your third-party
channels is a way to attract people into
deeper content on your site you're
pulling in traffic focus traffic
potentially high-volume traffic and
traffic that's emotionally invested
because if they've seen your content
somewhere and chosen to click into your
site they clearly have an intro it also
delivers links volume of links topical
links and credible links the idea of
social proofing so that has a big
potential benefit for you it can deliver
conversions it can be much easier to get
a conversion once you have someone in an
environment that you have more control
over than to get it out on a third-party
channel even as third-party channels are
improving their ability to get those
instant conversions you know when we
look at things like Twitter cards even
while those exist you still have more
control over the overall process in your
ability to test and refine it when it's
happening on your site and then finally
it's just a way to deliver credibility
because it lets you get out on some of
these channels and demonstrate that
knowledge and offer that teaser content
that says you're here you're present and
you have something to offer now one of
social media's biggest powers is the
concept of touch point ok it's important
to understand that being able to go and
meet customers where they already are
and lead them back to you that's where
social channels truly have their power
yes it's also in the connecting it's
also in the ability to drive engagement
and get exposure but those are your
starting points to get those conversions
there's a lot of value and inviting them
back into a place where they can engage
with you on a deeper level the other
thing to understand about touch points
is that the more times a consumer sees
your brand or campaign mentioned the
more likely they are to engage with it
again that's one of those areas of true
power and getting that exposure through
social media so if you look at each of
our little person icons here you look at
the sort of ripple effect circles that
are spreading out around them view each
of those
schools is a post to a social media
channel and maybe the bigger circles are
posted by an influencer in a specific
area and the smaller circles are posted
by you know friend or maybe a
lesser-known blogger Oh years ago with
candy crush saga which was a huge huge
mobile phenomenon here in the United
States most people didn't know about it
until a friend invited them to play and
most people probably got the half a
dozen dozen maybe two or three dozen
invites before they took the time to
check it out it takes a lot of exposure
a lot of your friends sharing the same
video or linking to the same news story
before you finally cave and gell okay
well if that many people think it's
worthwhile maybe I should take a look at
it so if you look at those places where
we have one person being impacted by
multiple ripple effects that's where we
see the highest likelihood of engagement
and that's where having a good presence
across social media channels and good
social sharing across social media
channels gives you those touch points
and those ability to draw people into an
experience with your company
now most social media channels have
slightly different reasons for existing
again we mentioned earlier and we're
going to talk a little bit later about
the fact that it's important to
customize the way you put your content
out there so that it has the highest
likelihood of catching the attention and
being engaged with by consumers so if we
look at things like micro media's
twitter and tumblr it's a great place to
sort of connect and listen same thing
with forums as we move down from say
forums to social networks now we're also
looking at building relationships and it
requires sort of a frequency of contact
and you can see that each of the
different forms of social channels has a
value to it and a specific thing that it
has the ability to accomplish now if
each of your social media efforts
connects back in to your home base you
have the ability to pass consumers
through multiple support channels and
you can play each channel to their
strengths to again create a better
experience where people can then come in
and engage with you on sort of your
owned media on the home base or the blog
or the area
you have created now a great example of
this of leveraging touch points is a
company called smarty hat a party it's a
party planning site they sell high-end
disposable party products you know
plates and glasses and things like that
and they do an excellent job of using
blog content and social channels to
attract visits and then leading buyers
from the blog into their sales process
so for example you can see here a
Facebook post they put up that talks
about a new product they've just
released they had a contest that went
with it and they give free product away
for a couple people and that they linked
into a blog post that they put together
that says here's how to use this product
to create favor or an appetizer or
something that you can use at your next
party now when you look at the blog post
they put up and you zoom in a little bit
you'll see that at the bottom they had a
link to go and buy the product so
they're using the Facebook post and a
teaser to draw people into their website
where they can give more information get
them more actively engaged and then
eventually push them into that
conversion funnel that's an example of
leveraging targeted touch points on a
specific social media channel to draw
someone in to a home base now let's see
this approach in action and how we can
take one of the ways that companies tend
to use social media and make a slight
tweak but really make a big difference
in their ultimate impact so an example
here is Belvedere flowers a small
florist in the u.s. that was using
YouTube to sell boxwood trees for
Christmas several years ago and they
ended up making a couple mistakes and
what's really interesting as I was
actually doing a webinar once where I
included them as an example and they
were actually on the call because it was
a florist webinar and they did end up
implementing some of these changes and
said it worked out really really great
so several years ago I was on Twitter
and I saw this tweet come by that said
boxwood trees are now available for
Philadelphia flower delivery your cat
will love them too it linked from
Twitter over to YouTube where there was
a little homemade YouTube video about
sort of the owners grandson decorating
this little box would tree and then I
think they took it off to a relative
that might have been in the nursing
facility you know where they couldn't
have a full Christmas tree cute video
does a decent
was making me go hey that might be
really good for my grandmother my
great-aunt now there's a couple
challenges here one of the big ones is
that you have to actually go and look
for the links there weren't there wasn't
anything embedded you know they didn't
have the call-outs with the link
straight in to go buy the product so you
have to actually look around and see if
you could figure out what the URL was or
go back and run a search for it
of course that's all assuming you don't
get distracted by all of the you know up
next or related videos and run off down
a rabbit trail that you know 20 minutes
later you find yourself going oh my
goodness why did I even come to YouTube
in the first place
we know that tends to happen there so
assuming you stayed focused and you
actually found that link and you clicked
into the site when I clicked into the
site there were no boxwood trees and I
looked all over for boxes with trees I
even used the search function to look
for box with trees and most people don't
tend to use the search function they
just go right back to Google and they
run a search again but as I was clicking
around I realized that actually had a
blog which means they had the
opportunity to write a great post about
the benefit of using boxwood trees for
aging relatives or in small apartments
and to embed that video right there into
the blog post because by embedding it
into the blog post now they're removing
some of the distractions of being in
that YouTube environment and they're
allowing me to be in their blog
environment where they're controlling
what the layout looks like on top of
that to also have the ability to put an
image and an Add to Cart and a call to
action button right there in the same
blog post to lead me into where I can
purchase that boxwood tree instead of
making me hunt around and look for it
now if you consider the difference of
making these slight changes you look at
the before-and-after you'll see that the
way they had it set up I had to be on
Twitter see that the tweet on Twitter
click into the video watch the video
look around for the URL to the site and
you know ignore all the other
distractions on YouTube click through to
the site search for the boxwood tree
read all the pricing and then click to
order now if you use this home base
mentality now when I'm on Twitter and I
see the
blank and I click I come into the blog
post and I can watch the video right
there on the blog post I can view the
pricing information right there on the
blog post and then I can click to order
that's two clicks instead of seven
different steps up in the first one now
if you know anything about conversion
optimization you know that the fewer
steps that you have the higher the
ultimate conversion rate so again very
very big difference and that's just in
the conversion process that doesn't even
count the inbound links the potential
for traffic traffic that might click
around other areas of the site and be
interested in a purchase lots of
benefits to looking at it from this new
perspective now a final word of advice
is that social media provides an amazing
opportunity to make a connection with
customers it's great to get out there on
different channels and really engage but
you need to remember to invite them into
your conversion funnel and a lot of
times that's going to mean inviting them
into your site or inviting them into
some point of conversion activity that
gives you the ability to contact and
engage with them in the future
[Music]
hey once you become an expert in digital
marketing then subscribe to the simply
learned Channel and click here to watch
more such videos turn up and get
certified in digital marketing click
here